officiellement ce n'était pas encore un
meeting de lancement de campagne pour
jean michel fourgous
pourtant la nécessité d'arpenter la 11e
circonscription pour porter la parole de
leurs candidats aux législatives a été
largement abordé ce mardi soir devant
les militants les républicains présents
battu en 2012 par benoît hamon le maire
d'elancourt entend récupérer son mandat
de député en juin et l'issue du scrutin
n'est pas encore écrite pré requis
indispensables à une victoire l'élection
en mai de françois fillon à la
présidentielle fillon a été premier
ministre d'une période difficile
1 où la france le monde a traversé une
crise mondiale très grave il a été il a
été bon donc un disque volant il a
l'expérience
bon il a été élu largement plus quelques
fois la surprise il faut bien le dire
aujourd'hui militants et sympathisants
sont invités à porter le projet de
françois fillon et à mettre fin aux
polémiques naissantes notamment autour
de la santé il faut simplement aux mrc
sur la table sans tabou
on est là pour améliorer les choses pour
que les français aient un système de
protection sociale qu'ils soient
performants qu'ils soient bien sûr qui
concerne tout le monde et en même temps
qu'ils soient financés le lancement
officiel de la campagne des législatives
côté républicain devrait intervenir fin
janvier dans la 11e on espère bien
mettre l'accent sur l'emploi ça dans les
quartiers on sent que c'est une vraie
attente on a beaucoup d'énergie des des
jeunes notamment qui veulent s'investir
qui veulent créer qui veulent innover
qu'ils sentent que l'économie allait
totalement verrouillé sur les sept
communes de la 11e circonscription sang
etc sont actuellement dirigées par la
droite mais la gauche de son visage et
résister avec la commune de trappes où
siège d'ailleurs un certain benoît
[Musique]